con casi 17.000 nuevos casos de kobe 19
colombia reportó el número más alto de
contagios diarios desde que el virus
llegó al país ya supera un millón
setecientos mil contagiados y solo
bogotá tiene casi el 30 por ciento de
ellos desde este martes la capital
retomo la cuarentena sectorizada tres de
las localidades más pobladas estarán
bajo confinamiento estricto hasta el 17
de enero en la consecuencia de un mal
comportamiento a final de año que la
gente se rajó y se fueron de vacaciones
salieron hubo muchos tumultos en las
compras y todo esto se nos olvidó pues
la amenaza del virus hay que ser
conscientes de ello y estamos pagando
las consecuencias
estas medidas se tomaron en medio de un
consecutivo aumento en la ocupación de
las unidades de cuidados intensivos
hasta ahora se desconoce si el gobierno
nacional estaría considerando
restricciones parecidas colombia también
anunció que su agencia de medicamentos
autorizó el uso de la vacuna de la dupla
faith ser valiente con las que había
negociado unas 10 millones de dosis este
es un paso muy importante y así
seguiremos también avanzando
con as transgénica y estaremos avanzando
también con janssen y estaremos
avanzando por supuesto con todas las
facilidades dentro de la estrategia
kóvacs según el gobierno colombia
tendría ya aseguradas las dosis
suficientes para vacunar unas 29
millones de personas de sus 50 millones
de habitantes la fase 1 de la campaña de
vacunación del gobierno que se espera
comienza dentro de las primeras semanas
de 2021 estará enfocada en trabajadores
de la salud así como en adultos mayores
de 80 años